good evening
and welcome to members and officers to
the rockford district council review
committee
of the 6th of july 2021
before we go to the meeting i'll read
out the emergency evacuation
announcement
should we be required to evacuate the
building would you please leave the
building via the rear doors of
to the hall turn right go through the
two sets of double doors to the car park
which is the assembly point please do
not delay
your evacuation to collect any
belongings
please do not return to the building
until given permission to do so
by council staff please note that the
meeting
will be audio recorded would you switch
off mobiles or turn them to silent
now members there are four microphones
on the tables for use during the meeting
and when i invite you to speak please
wait until there is a microphone in
front of you before speaking
as microphones are needed for the
hearing loop and for the audio recording
please wear possible assists in passing
the microphones to each other
and use the hand gel and antibacterial
wipes on the tables
if you do touch the microphones members
voting will be done
on a show of hands in line with the
constitution
i will ask for a show of those hands for
and then
against recommendations those abstaining
from voting
will be noted by the officers
we'll move to agenda item number one
apologies for absence apologies for
absence have been received from
councillors ian foster
mike wilkinson and james newport
gender item number two substitute
members
councillor carol weston is substituting
for councillor and foster
agenda item three non-members attending
we've got councils cheryl rowe simon
smith
simon wooten dave spering julie gooding
and arthur williams
agenda item number four minutes of the
meeting held on the 8th of june
2021 are those minutes agreed members
thank you agenda item number five to
receive declarations of interest
are there any declarations of interest
members
okay thank you so moving on to agenda of
item six which is the treasury
management annual review
2020 to 2021 naomi lucas the assistant
director for resources
will present the officer's report
council simon
smith the portfolio holder for financial
services
is also in attendance for this item
naomi thank you chair
uh this report sets out a summary of the
council's treasury management activity
for the 2021 financial year
um the council is required by the zipfor
code of practice on treasury management
to produce an annual review of its
activity each year
and the committee is asked to consider
the contents of the report
and recommend it for approval to full
council on the 20th of july
as i mentioned the council is required
by regulations
to undertake an annual review of its
treasury management activity this is the
third of three reports that the
committee receives each year
following its strategy in advance of
budget setting
which was on the 11th of february
2020 and then a mid-year update that
this committee received on the 15th of
december
the report follows its normal format
and sets out at section three the
investment performance for the last
financial year
members will see from the graph at
paragraph 3.3 the interest
rates have declined throughout the year
and they can see the council's
performance in terms of its investments
compared to
the bank of england base rates and the
libor average rates
further to that at section 4 um the
report sets out the investment position
for the council
and the amount of cash it's held for
investment during the course of the year
the table at 4.3 so the average sum that
was invested
um throughout the course of the year i
just note
that the balance at the start of the
year was unusually high
because that's when we had just received
a large amount
to pay out in terms of business grants
in relation to kovid
but most of that was paid out fairly
quickly so you'll see that that kind of
average drops quite quickly after the
start of the year and then kind of
flattens out for the
remaining course of the year
due to the low investment rates that
have been achievable this year
the council's investment returns
have totaled 68 000
pounds compared to um 147 000 pounds in
the previous financial year
um that's as a direct consequence of the
interest rates that i alluded to
previously
finally i'd just say that um as part
of this report i'm required to kind of
um
confirm that the council's operated
within its treasury limits and
prudential indicators as it's set out in
the treasury management strategy
so just like to draw members attention
to that fact
so i don't think there's anything else
that i was going to
add unless anyone's got any particular
questions they'd like to raise
mrs mason
thank you mr chairman through you i'd
like to ask the
officer to expand on some of the
information that
i believe we have requested in this
report previously
and that seems to be absent unless i've
misread it and apologies if i have
item 4.2
deals with the breakdown of investments
i'm assuming and perhaps
the first assumption the officer can
confirm if i'm correct that the six
million pounds placed with handles bank
and the two minutes in the prime
monetary fund
are on demand could you confirm that
because it's not
stated and yeah the the
amount placed with handles bank and is
um
instant access and again with the pro
money market fund that's
instant access yeah i think that needs
to be made clear
but my concern and what we've requested
before is that the interest rates and
the terms
for the fixed money is put into the
report
we've got three different fixed rates
with santander
there's no information on the length of
the terms or the interest rates that the
council is achieving there's one with
lloyds again
no interest or length of the fixed rate
term and i think it would be helpful to
have that included in the report if
you're not able to give it to us tonight
okay thank you for the comments and i'd
just say i think as i've
explained to committee members
previously that this is just kind of a
snapshot of the position at
year end and the um kind of terms of the
investment in terms of the interest rate
and will vary throughout the years so
um it really depends on an individual
day in terms of you know the interest
rate that might be
earned on a particular in investment so
i could obviously provide the terms
of those individual investments at that
31st march position but that wouldn't
necessarily represent
the position in terms of the investments
throughout the course of the year
yeah if i can come back on that it does
say here they're fixed rate interest
so if they're fixed rate the interest
rate logically is fixed
yeah so that that one with lloyds would
be fixed and santander
you've said you've got three fixed rate
investments
with santander totaling six million and
one fixed rate
investment of three millions with lloyds
whilst i accept that on demand money
the interest rate is normally flexible
when it's a fixed rate
the interest rate and the term is
normally known yeah so it would be fixed
for those
individualized investments that's what
i'm asking
at that point but i'm just saying that
the investment
rates may vary throughout the year
okay
councillor mrs gadsden
thank you chair um i just like to
understand
risk levels um i from looking at the
three
banks that we invest with i would
gather that the risk level of the money
being invested is
fairly low and i just wondered i'd
really just like to understand
what informs your decision on where you
invest the money
and at what risk level
thank you for your question um yeah so
essentially the risk appetite of the
council is determined by members as part
of the annual treasury management
strategy which is agreed by this
committee um
as i said um in february prior to it
being taken to war council
so um the council historically and
continues at the moment have very kind
of low
risk appetite so
we take advice from our treasury
management advisors who provide
kind of colour coding risk assessments
of all different types of investment
um and we yeah abide by the kind of
limits that we've set ourselves and
the color-coded guidance in terms of the
risk of individual investments but
yeah we only tend to invest in
um yeah banks or yeah
money markets which are very kind of low
risk and
very low risk indeed compared to other
products on the market
can i just ask sorry so do we have in
the financial expert that informs
members and officers on investments
that's outside
yeah we have an external consultant
through um link
who we procure so they're they're
investment
specialists surgery management advisors
so we take specialist advice from them
and they
advise us throughout the year and as i
say provide the kind of
risk matrix which informs our investment
decisions um
just one final question do we do
comparisons to
our investments compared to our how
other councils investments
strategy is working um yeah so obviously
the
kind of investment return will depend on
each council's individual risk profile
so they're not necessarily directly
comparable but
um we do um as part of the service link
provides
us and they provide kind of benchmarking
information
against the horrible authorities and
they've kind of said that
um in comparable terms our investment
rates that we achieve
are above um average you know that we
couldn't really achieve
any higher investment rate for the
the level of risk that we prepared to
take thank you for that
council trade please
thank you chairman my question is also
linked to link asset services
and as much as i would ask a question as
to whether
we are still happy with their services
and
whether they're on an annual renewable
contract
or whether it is a fixed term contract
and have we ever thought about
putting ourselves out to tender
thank you chairman
thanks thank you for your question um so
the answer is is yes um we procured the
service
on i think it's a three year contract
i'd have to
double check on that but we did procure
it um a year or so again ago
the there's only a limited number of
kind of providers that provide a similar
service
maybe two or three sort of key players
um
but yeah we do kind of review review the
service we've received and look at other
options
at the regular intervals okay so when
we eventually will go out a tender will
we to
um potentially or through a framework
which allows us to
um basically um
yeah a framework has been kind of
pre-assessed and and has preferred kind
of supplies on it and
but it it's a basically a procurement
exercise so there's different ways you
can do it but yeah we would
examine what's available thank you
thank you council smith please thank you
chairman
um as it clearly explains in 2.2
this this report is a delegated function
somewhat of a passenger on on this
journey but it is
large amounts of money that we're
talking about and um
it is part of our ongoing discussions
um you could look at 1.4
and describe the performance is
disappointing
because naomi's quite clearly pointed
out
trying to project forward in the current
climate is really
really challenging and the rates that
are available have been at a low
level so that as a result of that our
budget
has not been met but nevertheless our
performance
performances
is quite acceptable and for a good
number of years when we
do what benchmarking we can we do
perform fairly consistently
above the average and
and just uh just just a point on the um
table that's on of the graphics on 4.3
where naomi mentioned the larger amount
of money
we had at the start of the year
it it is just worth worth note the speed
with which we actually got that money
out of the door
to the businesses uh in the form of
grants that required it
in in the troubling times a couple of
members have mentioned um
link link services i mean it's a
relatively modest cost
per per year and as naomi said we we did
um
check on the value for money that we
achieved from that
um that service a year or so ago
and actually i do believe it provides
good value for money
and provides a level of expertise that
we could not reasonably be expected
to hold within a council of this size so
i believe the report is a good and
accurate representation of our
treasury management
thank you members there is one
recommendation
set out at paragraph 9.1
on page 6.4 of
the report 06.5 of the report
with those members in favor please raise
their hands
with those members against please raise
their hands
thank you that vote is unanimous then
the recommendation
is carried thank you
yes yes of course yep
moving on to item seven this is the
kovid 19
lessons learned and update report and
angela hutchings
the acting managing director will
present this report and we'll be able to
answer any questions
angela would you please present your
report
thank you chairman members this is this
is the third report detailing the
council's response to the covered 19
pandemic
six months on from the previous report
in that six months there has been a sea
change in the national position
culminating in the prime minister ready
to move to stage four of the covet mode
map in a little under two weeks time
the key issue for the council's offices
have been firstly the continuing
requirement to administer central
government financial hardship schemes
as a new line of service and secondly
the increase in businesses usual
services brought about by
increased demand and the fact that
people are working from home
and spending their time locally
this manifests members in terms of
increase
in waste and litter collection increases
in referrals to housing options and
revenues and benefits teams
increasing demands on environmental
health teams and licensing teams
and increases in domestic planning
applications
the council continues to manage its cove
its financial
code with pressures um and um the report
uh which was brought to um the executive
last month for the um uh quarter one
sets out
where we are in relation to that's where
the out year out turn
and is referenced in the financial
implications in this report
the council has adapted to return to a
physical environment for public meetings
and the elections of course in may
and we are preparing for a 19th july
stage for lifting of restrictions in
relation to our workforce
response to the staff survey
demonstrated the impact
on of covert 19 on the workforce and
with a relatively small workforce of 165
people
there are some deep pockets of
organizational stress
some other pockets of resilience however
but across the board high levels of work
intensity and increased
volumes of work presented support has
been put in place
for those employees and has been
positively received
but we increa and we increased the
frequency of internal communications and
targeted them specifically to health and
well-being
to ensure that we continue to talk about
the mental health and physical health
impacts of kobit 19.
the leadership team has put together
seven pledges in an action plan
in order to keep the subject current and
to respond
to the requirements from the
the staff to remove cultural barriers to
talking about stress
leading from the front in terms of role
models
and to look at our leadership and
management techniques to find ways to
remove stressors in the working
in the workplace and to work hard to
continue to create good physical
digital working environment and a work
life balance
in conclusion the last six months of the
pandemic have been probably more
difficult
than the beginning as although we we
knew more and we were more experienced
and had established a battle rhythm the
longevity of running in emergency mode
has been the defining feature of the
last six months
with energy levels lower than at the
beginning and with the
new normal um that living with covid
presents and it remains chairman to be
seen how the next six months indeed will
also pan
out chairman this is not an exhaustive
report so if there are other issues
which members would like me to bring
back to this committee later on the
municipal year i'll be happy to do so
thank you thank you do
any members have questions or
observations
thank you chairman um
i have a couple of questions and
observations if that's um
okay chairman uh 3.4
um actually sorry 3.2 first of all um it
discussed
um that there's current offers of
support from the
um hub that was put together um during
covid
could the officer explain and give a
little bit more detail
on that support then 3.4
is the rise directly related to covid
for example furloughed residence
3.9 it's interesting to note
um dealt with
local outbreaks in a timely fashion i
just wonder what
timely fashion actually means
in time and also with the local
outbreaks is this similar
outcome with other councils
and if so can we influence future
occurrences
should there be a further outbreak of
covid
or similar and
my last question is on 5.2
the officer mentioned that there are
barriers and stigma around mental health
now when staff are accessing the
employee assistant program
one do we know the take up
and i'm hoping that it is confidential
and although numbers may be provided to
the council not necessarily
staff details thank you chairman
thank you chairman that's quite a lot if
i can just
i'm going with me what i'll just go
through
so taking those in order in relation to
paragraph 3.2 and the continuing support
um provided by the hob with the hub the
hub
so the the hub has
as you know was essentially a
partnership between watchful district
council and
a number of voluntary sector partners
as we moved through the first
phase of the of the pandemic and towards
the second lockdown period
the ownership effectively of that hub
moved from the council towards
the um to the community support
and they took over and began to own and
run it
in uh in terms of mobilizing support in
the
volunteer network um working continuing
to work in partnership with the council
as and reporting to the health and
well-being board the
um the the ongoing work
it remains exemplar and as it says in
that
paragraph essex county council is
looking to continue to support that work
it remains the case that the bonds that
have been
built by the volunteers and those
who were supported um amongst the
clinically um vulnerable have remained
to be incredibly strong
and so the informal networks that
continue to provide
help support shopping prescriptions
and general befriending continues um
notwithstanding the
the actual um hub itself so
the networks and across very strong and
indeed
from the church network in particular uh
in relation to how that community
support
continues so it is it is remaining
in relation to paragraph 3.4 the
question was asked whether
the number of approaches to the council
how counseling options service was
directly related to copic 19.
um chairman i can't answer that question
uh forensically this evening um but i
can take that away
if that would uh suffice but certainly
it is
the the increase is is directly as a
consequence of
um covert 19 although i can't say
whether it is linked to furloughs etc
but it is for example we saw um
displacements created by
uh certainly during lockdown periods
through domestic violence
uh and through other um strained family
situations where
people presented as homeless
in paragraph 3.9 the question was asked
about
how the the environmental health team
resolving
cases in a timely fashion the
the issue for the council's
environmental health team is part of the
second tier response to essex county
council's
first tier track and trace was to follow
up local contacts
across the district as information was
given to
um to us i can't give you an
average turnaround time although again i
can take that away and ask that question
for you
but um the team in terms of providing
timely fashion is to
contact trace and and provide that
information back to essex county council
so that the nhs
test and trace team could reach out and
make contact to them
and uh isolation periods could begin so
it was as i certainly know that
there were occasions when information
wasn't provided to us
as quickly as it might otherwise have
been but that the team
then capitalized on that and tried to
make up for lost time by getting out
there as quickly as possible
in terms of our response similar to
other councils and can we influence the
environmental health team were part of a
24-hour
seven days a week rota along with
district council
colleagues from across the county so the
response was
pretty uniform some authorities have
more available offices than others and a
number of our
environment environmental health team
were in fact actually clinically
vulnerable and were shielding
so we were part of a joint effort across
the county so
certainly in terms of ongoing influence
i expect very much that the dependency
on the environmental health
colleagues at second-tier councils will
continue
the prime minister made direct reference
to continuing track and trace
regardless of what life looks like after
the 19th of july
so and we absolutely are part of that
and that team
meets weekly with the director of public
health
and information is provided and cascaded
to that team
in relation to local outbreaks and how
to
to manage them the environmental health
team
already had an extremely good working
relationship with businesses
and during the certainly the the peak of
the pandemic there were they were
working with businesses um consistently
to ensure that those that were able to
operate could operate and could operate
safely and those that were prohibited
from opening
remained closed and as we've moved
through
the unlocking process in conjunction
with colleagues from licensing
the environmental health team has
continued to take a really proactive
approach to working with businesses
to help them reopen safely and to give
confidence to
to to shoppers and to residents to
continue to use those services
but equally has has not shied away from
bringing enforcement action when
required to do so
but it has been very much the exception
rather than the rule and the
continuing approach appears to be one of
again working on those good working
relationships
the next question chairman that was
asked was in relation to
the employee assistance program so yes
the employee assistance
program has been in place for quite some
considerable time it predates um the
pandemic it is a
a response which the council has offered
for
several years now we do know that it was
taken up but it includes
free counselling services for employees
and of course yes it is absolutely
confidential
we have um a mental health first aider
who's been providing support
we've seen that that person has not been
as well received as the employee
assistance scheme
simply because they are another member
of staff and we as a council i think are
too small
and therefore that issue of confidence i
think is is a barrier to accessing the
mental health first aider
so what we're looking to do is to work
with another authority to
effectively body up with somebody from
outside the organization so that there's
somebody entirely independent
with whom officers can speak if they
if they would like to do so
and chairman i think those are the
questions that were asked
thank you just
uh the russian district community have
therefore continues
with partners to develop current offers
of support
and if we could have some feedback on
what those offers of support are just so
that we can see
any remaining sort of gaps in provision
in our community
no problem thank you so much for a very
comprehensive report
thank you thank you council mrs mason
thank you mr chairman i'd just like to
ask the officer through you to expand
slightly on
3.4 i think
councilman mrs mcpherson has raised
a very important question but the table
that would be shown
only goes up to march and yet it says
we're expecting an increase
following the removal of the rental
eviction oratorium on the 1st of june
21. we're now on the 6th of july
when would we expect to have the last
quarters figures
it's over a month now
um chairman um louisa moss assistant
director for people and communities
provides a quarterly
update which is provided to members so
i'd expect that information to be in
there but i can
ask her to provide it to this committee
outside of this meeting
i think it would have been helpful in
this report mr chairman
to have up-to-date information and
just one other slight question
3.13 we said that the south street
custom reception has
reinstated face-to-face services for our
customers on appointment basis
do we know what the demand for that has
been
the demand has been steady and
consistent
in that appointments offered have been
accepted but it hasn't yet been
overwhelmed
following the 19th of july when we
reopen
reception with a receptionist we'll be
doing much more information gathering
and data analysis to make sure
we understand how many people are
actually coming on to site
thank you mr chairman council mr shaw
that one off
thank you again
um
there was always an inevitability in
terms of losing volunteers as people
uh returned to the workplace um but um
yes i can get some further information
thank you very much thank you members
this will indulge me i've just got
one question really the opposite which
is um from what we've learned
so far from the pandemic how do you see
the future working patterns for our
staff
the information that we have from the
staff surveys
shows that predominantly the agile
working policy has been successful and
officers like the flexibility of being
able to manage
their workload and their location
work being something that you do not
necessarily somewhere that you go
but there is equally a a demand for
coming on to site
not just for seeing clients but also
for undertaking peer support work and
working collaboratively as part of the
team and what is clear
is that social isolation is equally
destructive
as the risk of covered in in a
larger environment i'm expecting
to see a gradual drift back to the south
street offices
as confidence increases and as teams
become used to working together again
and that will be a very positive
thing to see but we are seeing that in
terms of managing the work-life balance
the agile working policy
with a new flexi time policy that we're
bringing in as well
is meeting um most of our office's
requirements
we have to be careful and guard against
a sort of an
off an extra hours kind of culture
where it's difficult for officers to
separate out their working environment
and being at home and if you're
working from home all the time that's
actually very difficult to manage
um so a working in a hybrid fashion
going forward is
seems to be the the conclusion of the um
of the uh the staff survey and there are
some teams for example
the revenues and benefits team and the
planning team
where working collaboratively with
colleagues actually creates a better
product
um it provides peer support um allows
people to bounce ideas from one another
uh and generally it means that the sort
of an internal quality assurance takes
place which is very difficult to do when
you're
working by yourself whereas there are
other offices for whom that's that's
less of
an issue many of our officers continue
to work from site as they have done
throughout
our licensing team for example continues
to um to see
taxi drivers you know and other
applicants in a code secure way
although they were the one of the first
in the county to pioneer
digital ways of working so the
creativity and innovation that the
pandemic has caused i think
means that we can pick out the good bits
that we would like to take going forward
but i think
um the mandate that
they need no longer work from home will
be positively received
thank you um
members there's one recommendation that
paragraph 14.1
on page 7. 7.12
of the report which is to note the
report is the report
noted members
thank you thank you
we now move on to item eight which is
the key decisions document and what i
intend to do is to go through a page at
a time
and if anyone has any questions or
observations on the items
please let me know so
on page two we've got
the modern slavery act 2015
and the suspension of parking charges on
saturdays before
christmas any observations
or comments
okay move on to page three
and we've got the voluntary sector grant
allocation 2022 to 2023
and the connect programme investor saved
business case
and pipeline of projects
any comments or observations
thank you move on to page four which is
the
association of south essex local
authorities
and the parks for nature
any observations or comments
okay okay and then on
page five we've got the waste transfer
arrangements
any observations or comments
thank you members we now move on to
item 9 which is the work plan
and um
we've got the the published work plan
which is
as from the last meeting um
but we've currently got an existing
working group which is the open spaces
working group
which council mr shaw and council mrs
mason and
councillor sperringer's are members of
um but what i'd like to do is i'd like
to ask
councillor mrs mason if she could give a
quick verbal update
on the work of the great police
thank you mr chairman yes i'm i'm happy
to do that
the open spaces management working group
um was formulated i think it was back in
2019
in january 20 the working group asked
officers for four items of information
the lack of response to these requests
in a timely fashion
and the changes the subsequent pandemic
pandemic
created led to a delay in the group
setting up a further meeting
towards the end of last year these items
were chased
and some information was provided
including a report
that although not requested has had been
commissioned by officers and was
informative
and helpful however
although requested the group has not
received the information regarding the
cost of that report
to date despite the lack of resources
the working group reconvened after the
election and we have managed
with our office administration to move
forward relatively quickly
and the working group is working well in
this different
different formats i would like to thank
all members participating
for their constructive input and
willingness to embrace a new way
of working and i would mention again
that the names of those
members because they have been very
constructive council phil shaw
councillor michael high health david
sparing
and the chairman himself of course
the open spanish spaces
the open spaces management working group
is in the process of drafting report
which will be presented to this
committee for consideration
and subsequent presentation to full
council
it is anticipated that this will be
ready for the september meeting
a recommendation from the open spaces
working group is as follows
that the problem of the historic sites
be addressed by a separate working group
with a suggestion that this be done on a
site-by-site basis
and that consideration is given to the
birds estate
at first as there are known issues we've
we did find
mr chairman that the complexity of
two competing um
ideologies was probably not helping the
group
so that's the meaning behind that
recommendation so i'd like that
um adding on to the work plan if the
committee so agrees
and hopefully we will as i say be able
to give you a full report
in september thank you
members but from my perspective this
group works really well
not because i'm on it in spite of me
being on it i would say
um but it's very flexible it's a good
way of working
what it does is it means that members
are actively involved and it minimizes
the load that we put on to officers so
rather than have
overloading officers and having them
beckon call
it means that it's it's truly a member
led up i don't want to put you on the
spot
counselor mr shaw but what what's your
perception of it
thank you chairman um yeah so
we've met twice unfortunately i wasn't
able to
go to the first meeting
i wasn't able to go the first video but
the second one
everybody seems to be working well
together
and the last meeting we agreed to go
away
um and look at one subject
and we're all going to come back and
then discuss that subject
but it is working well without you to
say without the officer's input
we've managed to do a lot ourselves and
we can go back and recommend things
to this committee when we got everything
together but it is working really good
thanks
and i don't want you to get the
impression that there is no officer
involvement at all there is
but what we're trying to do is minimise
the load on the officers
so that we can cover more ground by
doing that
thank you chairman um
um is there an officer that takes
minutes at the
meeting just for the records
no that doesn't mean to say they
couldn't be
it's just that it's almost a
self-managing
working group yeah
for clarity minutes are not kept but
notes are kept
of the meeting and are circulated and
agreed
so they're not formal minutes working
groups don't tend to have
formal minutes anyway but they're kept
by a member of the group but
as it happens i'm keeping them i
circulate them almost straight away
if anyone has any um well it's any
further input into those notes i want
them altered then that is done
so that it's a very collaborative way of
working
but it doesn't have to be myself as
chairman that's actually doing that any
member of the group
could do that if they so wished but
notes are kept
and are on record
thank you for clarifying um that
i'm just mindful that perhaps within the
office there should be some sort of
record of these meetings so perhaps
those minutes are passed on
to an officer you could do yeah
thank you chairman yeah okay um
and as a as a principle the i would like
to establish
more of these working groups through the
year um and there's a couple of
um areas that have been suggested to
work one is
is around um the section 106
work which is from the
initial concept and outline of what
what section 106 is going to provide in
a development
through to the actual implementation
because sometimes
what what members are saying to me is
what's delivered isn't always what was
agreed
at the development committee so it's
perhaps looking at those arrangements
and also something that which is quite
topical is
the processes around um how assets are
released to third parties
from uh mechanics to
town of host councils perhaps charities
or to community groups so those are the
sorts of
flavors of topics i'm just waiting for
the ads to get back to me so that we can
actually formally scope that
and what i intend to do is out of
committee is to write to members to see
what
whether you're interested in being a
member on any of those working groups
so that that's the way that i would like
to work
one thing i would say is don't overload
yourself if it turns out there's lots of
these working groups going on
don't overload yourself and end up doing
nothing and chasing yourself
go for things that you're you're
interested in
are there any questions on
working groups remember working
okay thank you that um
that is the final um agenda item
so i declare the meeting closed at
20 18
thank you members
step